Вуличне мистецтво живе
на вулицях, на стінах.
Це насамперед просто красиво.
Сєверодонецьк — дуже компактне місто.
Це моє рідне місто,
я його дуже люблю,
мені здається, тут дуже
комфортно перебувати.
Тут дуже багато стін,
дуже багато потенціалу,
є де малювати —
це дуже круто для мене.
Я позиціоную себе насамперед
як графіті-художник.
Я вже більше 12 років малюю графіті.
Зараз подивимось стіни.
Коли почав навчатись тут у місті,
були такі думки переїхати кудись:
до Харкова, до Києва, можливо.
Але почав вчитись,
поки вчився,
паралельно малював.
Потім влаштувався на роботу
і також малював весь цей час.
Один об'єкт, другий, третій і все,
і вже й такого бажання немає.
Для мене ціль тут залишити
щось після себе.
Хочу розвивати саме вуличне
мистецтво в себе в регіоні.
Я хочу, щоб більше людей
сюди приїжджали малювати.
Звісно, мені цікавий розвиток
саме тут, на Донбасі, Луганщині.
Мені подобається навколо себе
щось змінювати, людям також.
На початку, звісно,
це нерозуміння взагалі.
Ніякого розуміння не було:
що ми робимо, хто ми такі,
як інопланетяни якісь.
Я розумів,
що якщо я намалюю квіти,
то це більш-менш всім підійде,
нікого не зачепить.
І плюс до цього, це як подарунок
до Дня міста був, такий букет квітів.
Людям «зайшло» під кінець вже,
коли тут вимальовувалось щось.
Пішло-поїхало все.
А потім реставрували оцю тепличку,
і на нас самі вийшли і сказали:
«Хлопці, прийдіть
і що-небудь намалюйте.
Що от бачите,
ось так і робіть».
Так і повинно бути,
тому що в нас вже є якийсь досвід,
ми давно цим займаємось,
і якось треба довіряти,
йти на контакт.
Тим паче, у нас портфоліо є,
роботи по місту.
Тому я працюю в авторському стилі,
і мені це подобається.
Люди дуже позитивно реагують,
навіть вчителі образотворчого
мистецтва виходили.
Дивились і казали:
«Як? Як такі палітри робив?»
А це дуже просто,
це ж квіти і є.
Яка там палітра — рожеві та зелені,
ну це є квіти, он вони і є.
Будь ласка, заходьте, дивіться.
Ось ці кольори, нічого важкого.
Усе тут, треба тільки дивитись.
З технічного боку,
це починається з того,
що ми підготовлюємо стіну.
Перш за все, ми її фарбуємо в один колір.
Потім переносимо ескіз:
якщо це невелика стіна,
то власноруч,
а якщо це масштабна стіна,
то ми з проєктора працюємо,
бо це полегшує задачу
і це дуже швидко.
Тому що автовишка — це дуже дорого,
і треба в темпі працювати.
Тому ми працюємо в темпі так,
нон-стопом.
Це виглядає як розфарбовка,
і далі ми додаємо кольори,
потихеньку заливаємо кожен
трикутничок, квадратик.
У нас такі є табу:
наприклад, не чіпати пам'ятки
архітектури, пам'ятники.
У жодному разі.
Це табу.
Також у нас було багато художників свого часу,
багато хлопців починали,
але всі з різних причин припинили.
Хтось і досі малює,
але всі кудись роз'їхались,
бо ще й війна.
Я почав далі шукати можливості,
як ще можна реалізуватись
і куди податись.
Я не знав про існування таких грантів,
якихось міжнародних підтримок.
Але в ГО, яка допомогла
з першим муралом, мені підказали,
що можливо звернутися до ПРООН.
У них є абсолютно різні програми,
спрямовані на культуру, зокрема.
І вони сказали:
«Можеш спробувати туди сходити».
Я слухав все уважно, записував.
Потім приїхав додому,
написав свою заявку,
подали її завдяки ГО до ПРООН,
і ця заявка пройшла.
Нам виділили фінансування на два мурали:
це був наш міський
автовокзал і університет.
І після цього в нас щороку
є стабільна співпраця.
Цього року теж планується вже такий,
я б сказав, немалий, це точно, проєкт.
Це по області будуть мурали,
зокрема, у Сєвєродонецьку буде один мурал.
Це така арка,
уся в якихось старих оголошеннях,
і світла немає.
Увечері йдеш — дуже темно.
Я не кажу, що ми ремонт
генеральний робимо, але...
Що з цим робити, я не знаю.
Я ж не будівельник,
це не в наших силах.
Ми робимо те,
що нам під силу.
Ось у нас залишилась фарба
з якогось проєкту,
ми прийшли, помалювали,
люди ходять.
Звісно, це краще, ніж от
(як там бачите) стіни сипляться.
Оцей провисить тут,
я думаю, довго,
тому що тут тінь,
сонце не потрапляє.
Залишити хочу слід у житті міста,
щоб пам'ятали, знаєте?
Оці стіни будуть висіти тут десять,
двадцять років, не знаю, скільки.
Пробуємо ж робити найкраще.